this is from the graph basic exponential
functions on khan academy and they ask
us graph the following exponential
function and they give us the function h
of x is equal to 27 times one-third to
the x so our initial value is 27 and
one-third is our common ratio it's
written in kind of standard exponential
form and they give us this little
graphing tool where we can define these
two points and we can also define
we can define a horizontal asymptote to
construct our function and these three
things are enough to define to to graph
an exponential if we know that it is an
exponential function so let's think
about it a little bit so the easiest
thing that i could think of is well
let's think about its initial value its
initial value is going to be when x
equals 0 x equals 0 it's 1 3 to the 0
power which is just 1 and so you're just
left with 27 times 1 or just 27. that's
why we call this number here when you're
written it in this form you call this
the initial value so when x is equal to
h of x is equal to 27 and we're graphing
y equals h of x
so now let's graph another point so
let's think about it a little bit
when
when x is equal to 1 when x is equal to
1 what is h of x
well it's going to be 1 3 to the first
power which is just 1 3 and so 1 3 times
27 is going to be 9. so when h when x is
h of 1 is
and we can verify
well and now let's just think about
let's think about the asymptote so
what's going to happen here when x
becomes really really really really
really really big
well if i take one third to like a
really large exponent to say to the to
the 10th power to the hundredth power or
to the thousandth power this thing right
over here is going to start approaching
zero as we get as x becomes much much
much much larger and so something that
is approaching 0 times 27 well that's
going to approach 0 as well so we're
going to have a horizontal asymptote at
0. and you can verify that this works
for more than just the two points we
thought about when x is equal to 2 this
is telling us that the graph y equals h
of x goes through the point 2 comma 3.
so h of 2 should be equal to 3 and you
can verify that that is indeed the case
if x is 2 1 3 squared is 9 oh sorry 1 3
squared is 1 9
times 27 is 3 and we see that right over
here when x is 2 h of 2 is 3. so i feel
pretty good about that let's do another
one of these
so graph the following exponential
function so same logic x is when x is 0
the g of 0 is just going to it's just
going to boil down to that initial value
and so let me scroll down the initial
value is negative 30.
and so let's think about when x is equal
to one when x is equal to one two to the
first power is just two and so two times
negative thirty is negative sixty so
when x is equal
when x is equal to one
the value of the graph is negative
60.
now let's think about let's think about
this
asymptote where that should sit
so let's think about what happens when x
becomes really really really really
really really negative
so when x is really negative
so two to the negative one power is one
half to the negative two is one fourth
two to the negative three is one eighth
as you get larger and larger negative or
higher magnitude negative values or in
other ways as x becomes more and more
and more negative
two to that power is going to approach
zero and so negative 30 times something
approaching zero is going to approach
zero so this asymptotes in the right
place our horizontal asymptote as x as x
approaches negative infinity as we move
further and further to the left the
value of the function is going to
approach zero and we can see it kind of
approaches zero from below we can see
that it approaches below because we
already looked at the initial value and
we used that common ratio to find one
other point hopefully you found that
interesting